[Musique]
un suicide c'est toujours une mort de
trop
on a quand même chercher à savoir si le
taux de suicide chez les jeunes avait
évolué au cours des dernières années
[Musique]
dans les années 80 puis les années 90 le
taux de suicide chez les jeunes hommes
québécois était largement supérieur à la
moyenne canadienne
au québec on a atteint des pointes de 40
suicides par cent mille habitants alors
que la moyenne nationale était de 10
suicides par cent mille habitants
en fait le taux de suicide chez les 15 à
24 heures au québec étaient parmi les
plus élevés dans le monde
à l'époque les chercheurs montraient du
doigt l'éclatement de la famille le
manque de soutien offert aux adolescents
ou leurs difficultés à s'imaginer un bel
avenir
la cyberintimidation
ça fait mal par là la bonne personne tel
jeunes depuis 30 ans le québec a
multiplié les efforts en matière de
prévention de sensibilisation
ce qui fait que dans les années 2000
puis 2010 on a vu le taux de suicide
chez les jeunes québécois baisser
significativement pour rejoindre
aujourd'hui la moyenne nationale
mais comme on le disait un suicide c'est
toujours une mort de trop
oui il y as d'amélioration le canada
fait mieux par exemple que les états
unis ou les pays scandinaves mais il
reste encore du travail à faire
chez les gens autochtone par exemple le
rapport du fédéral disait dans les
années 80 qu'un taux de suicide des
jeunes autochtones étaient dix fois plus
élevé que chez les blancs et dans
plusieurs communautés
la situation ne s'est pas améliorée pour
vérifier quelque chose
voici l'adresse